SO A STADIUM BEARS LOADS
JUST LIKE A REGULAR BUILDING,
BUT UNLIKE A REGULAR BUILDING,
YOU CAN'T HAVE A LOT OF BEAMS TO
SUPPORT THE ROOF IN THE MIDDLE,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD
OBSTRUCT THE VIEW,
WHICH IS THE WHOLE REASON
YOU GO TO A STADIUM.
OTHER THAN THE HOT DOGS.
YOU HAVE TO DESIGN SUCH THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE THE FORCES ARE GOING
AND HOW TO DIRECT THEM.
THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
STADIUM
ACTUALLY EMPLOYS BRUNEL TRUSSES.
THIS IS A KIND OF STRUCTURE
THAT REALLY SUPPORTS
THE STADIUM'S ROOF
USING AN ARCH THAT'S FORMED
OF A LOT OF TRIANGLES
TO BEAR THE LOAD.
Narrator: LET'S EXAMINE
THE STRENGTH OF TRIANGLES.
RECTANGLES,
WHEN SUBJECTED TO FORCE,
EASILY COLLAPSE INTO RHOMBUSES.
BUT A TRIANGLE DISTRIBUTES FORCE
DOWN ITS SIDES
AND MAINTAINS ITS SHAPE.
Man: SO TAKE THIS TRIANGLE
AND START TILTING IT
AND TRACE WHERE THE TIP IS,
AND WHAT SHAPE DOES IT MAKE?
AND ARCH.
SO, THE STRONGEST POINT
OF AN ARCH
IS ALMOST EVERY POINT
ALONG ITS CURVE,
AND IF YOU WANT TO SUPPORT THAT,
JUST ADD MORE TRIANGLES.
Narrator: YOUR TRUSSES WILL BE
MADE OF SOLID STEEL.
EACH WILL MEASURE 700 FEET LONG,
87 FEET HIGH,
AND 17 FEET WIDE,
AND WEIGH 3.6 MILLION POUNDS.
I CAN'T EVEN FATHOM THAT IS.
EVERYTHING IS MEASURED,
TO ME, IN DONUTS,
SO THAT'S A LOT OF DONUTS.
[ DING! ]